la scène va durer quelques secondes à
peine
alerté par les coups de feu une employée
de l'hôpital se précipite vers la
voiture
Monaco le 28 mai dernier à 11h un
événement dramatique vient à sombrer ce
début d'été
ce jour-là on enterre Hélène Pastor la
femme la plus riche de Monaco
des obsèques presque en cachette
aucune annonce officielle de
l'enterrement n'a été faite
[Musique]
entouré de leur garde du corps seuls les
plus proches de la défunte sont là
nous parvenons à filmer quelques images
mais tout a été fait pour que la presse
ne soit pas là
[Musique]
au bout de quelques minutes nous sommes
refoulés brutalement
mais je parle les policiers sont nerveux
le ton monte rapidement ici on ne
s'approche pas de la famille Pastor
et si ça vous va pas vous prenez vos
affaires vous partez et bien on va
c'est très bien vous croyez quoi vous
croyez comme en France ici ça se passe
comme ça si ça vous plaît pas c'est la
même chose
ça ne se passe pas comme en France car
ici nous sommes à Monaco
une principauté autonome enclavé entre
la France et l'Italie
un état de 2 km² peuplé de nombreux
millionnaires à Monaco les résidents
étrangers ne payent quasiment pas
d'impôts 35000 habitants à peine qui ne
se remettent pas du meurtre de celle
qu'on appelait la vice princesse de
Monaco
Ellen Pastor 77 ans victime le 9 mai
dernier d'un terrible guet-apens devant
l'hôpital l'archet de Nice alors qu'elle
rendait visite à son fils Gildo malade
c'est ici qu'elle a été victime de
plusieurs coups de feu avec son
chauffeur Mohamed Darouiche alors
qu'elle rendait visite à son fils
hospitalisé à Nice Hélène Pastor a été
pris pour cible par un tireur qui a pris
la fuite l'enquête ne fait que commencer
un crime commis de sang-froid et à bout
portant
les tueurs n'ont laissé aucune chance à
Hélène Pastor et son chauffeur ce sont
des armes létales qui ont des
destructions multiviscérales qui sont
des armes de chasse pour le pour le gros
gibier normalement et qui entraîne des
lésions multiples parce qu'il y a de
très nombreux projectiles
[Musique]
chez au coup au visage et aux thorax
Ellen Pastor décédera de ses blessures
deux semaines plus tard quelques jours
après son chauffeur
l'affaire fait la Une de la presse
la France découvre le nom des pastors
inconnu jusque là du grand public
une famille pourtant très proche des
Grimaldi les princes de Monaco
qui pouvaient en vouloir à une Pastor
s'agit-il d'un règlement de compte
familial ou d'un crime crapuleux à
travers Hélène le clan Pastor était-il
visé
Monaco comme tous les jours à midi c'est
la relève de la garde princière
devant le palais les touristes sont au
rendez-vous la Principauté est célèbre
grâce à la famille Grimaldi ces
princesses glamour Charlène et Caroline
pourtant il existe une autre dynastie
sur le rocher celle de la famille Pastor
moins connu que les Grimaldi mais
beaucoup plus riche que leur nom
s'affiche partout ce sont dit-on ici les
vrais maîtres du rocher au lendemain de
la mort d'Hélène Pastor le prince Albert
exprime à titre personnel sa tristesse
et son émotion dans un communiqué
dans la ville la famille Pastor impose
ce petit bandeau noir en signe de deuil
sur toutes ces enseignes et il y en a
partout car la famille Pastor contrôle
près du tiers du parc immobilier de
Monaco
4000 appartements jusqu'à 50000 euros le
mètre carré en bord de mer
Frédéric Laurent et historien de Monaco
c'est un fin connaisseur de la famille
Pastor
là il y a deux immeubles à construire
dans les années 70 par judo Pastor mais
là on est en face le l'immeuble très
emblématique construit par Pastor au
début des années 60 donc derrière moi
c'est le Baya des fleurons de de
l'Empire immobilier de laine Pastor cet
immeuble avec les tentures bleus qui
s'appelle le Chouki c'est un des
premiers grands immeubles pasteur à
Monaco l'ensemble immobilier qui est
derrière moi le long du front de mer
c'est une grande partie de l'empire
Pastor en Principauté c'est la première
fortune de la Principauté plus
importante que la fortune princière
l'ampère Pastor il est difficile à
évaluer mais il tourne entre 15 et 20
milliards d'euros environ
une fortune d'environ 20 milliards
d'euros amassés en quelques décennies
seulement une success story incroyable
celle d'un simple maçon italien
Jean-Baptiste Pastor arrivé à Monaco au
début du 20e siècle il monte une petite
entreprise de bâtiments que son fils
Gildo fait ensuite prospéré
Gildo est interviewé ici en 196
pasteur ensuite c'est poursuivie elle a
été créée en 193 jusqu'à l'année 38 date
à laquelle j'ai été le créateur
en Principauté de Monaco de la
copropriété pierre abramovici a écrit un
livre sur la fortune de la famille il
nous explique la méthode Pastor
Gildo Pastor en fait son coup de génie
c'est de précisément acheter des
terrains tout ce que vous voyez là le
bord de mer c'est à lui et il ne le vend
jamais et au fil du temps il va en
garder la propriété et simplement le
louer et ce qui va faire la fortune de
la famille Pastor c'est le coup de génie
Gilles de Pastor de garder en propre
tout le bord de mer ne jamais vendre les
immeubles toujours les louer avec ces
milliers d'appartements la famille
Pastor et la principale agence de
location du rocher l'argent rentre
rapidement les héritiers de Gildo le
gèrent avec habileté Gigo Pastor a trois
enfants le premier d'entre eux c'est
Victor le second c'est Michel la
troisième c'est Hélène et son fils qui
va être derrière Gildo junior
Victor Pastor c'est la partie
construction Michel plus ou moins avec
différentes variantes c'est en gros la
partie vente immobilière quant à Hélène
Pastor la dernière c'est en fait
simplement l'exploitation du patrimoine
immobilier existant comme héritière des
trois elle est la seule à ne pas être
concrètement ce qu'on appelle une femme
d'affaires
Michel Pastor est le seul de la fratrie
à se montrer en public il a présidé le
club de foot de l'AS Monaco pendant 5
ans avant de mourir l'an dernier elle
aime Pastor était au contraire une femme
discrète gérant seul son héritage de 5
milliards d'euros elle ne s'affichait
pas dans les soirées il n'existe d'elle
que de très rares photos
loin du luxe elle habitait un
appartement au sein d'un des immeubles
qu'elle possédait
qu'est-ce que vous risquez si vous dites
je risque rien à moi mais j'ai donné des
moments donnés des ordres c'est tout
la direction finalement l'employé nous
dira tout de même quelques mots sur sa
patronne comment était elle madame
pastorale très généreuse
une femme qui connaissait son métier
elle était menacée selon vous
elle avait pas de garde rien sortie
normalement avec son chauffeur départ
elle allait aucune crainte elle aime
Pastor ne se sentait pas menacé
pourtant c'est bien elle que les Turcs
semblaient attendre le 6 mai dernier à
Nice
ce jour-là il est environ 16 heures
quand la riche héritière sort comme tous
les jours de son bureau
son chauffeur Mohamed Darwich l'attend à
bord de son monospace de couleur noire
direction l'hôpital l'archet de Nice a
une douzaine de kilomètres de Monaco
comme d'habitude depuis plusieurs
semaines elle va y rendre visite à son
fils Gildo victime d'un avc
au même moment d'après nos informations
un des tueurs serait lui aussi en route
vers l'hôpital
partie de Marseille il aurait pris un
train jusqu'à la gare de Nice puis un
taxi dans un sac de sport il aurait
dissimulé l'arme du crime
devant l'hôpital un deuxième homme un
guetteur la tendrait déjà
David Di Giacomo journaliste à France
Bleu Nice enquête depuis le début sur ce
crime
et là quand il sort ce de l'hôpital
l'archet à priori le tireur est caché
ici il avait semble-t-il un fusil de
chasse et là il tire à deux reprises du
côté passager il touche le chauffeur il
touche également Hélène pasteur donc
cette scène de crime a vraiment eu lieu
là ensuite la voiture a roulé un petit
peu et elle a été immobilisée
la scène va durer quelques secondes à
peine
alerté par les coups de feu une employée
de l'hôpital se précipite vers la
voiture
j'étais au niveau des portes en fait
quand j'ai entendu les coups de feu donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai été en courant
voir ce qui se passait pour voir si je
pouvais aider le chauffeur il avait un
impact de balle au niveau du thorax avec
plusieurs
plusieurs éclats éclats en fait comme
des petites billes madame Pastor est
blessée au niveau du visage et ça me
faisait un trou en fait au niveau du
visage avec pareil plusieurs impacts de
sang un peu partout
criblés de balle Hélène Pastor peut
pourtant encore parler l'infirmière
recueillera ses derniers mots avant
qu'elle ne perde connaissance
madame Pastor l'as seule image que j'ai
c'est qu'elle demandait en fait après
son chien dans sa voiture dans sa
voiture
en fait parce qu'il était à l'arrière et
le chien n'est pas blessé
le tueur et son complice repartent
calmement à pied sous le regard de
nombreux passants un départ devant
témoin très loin des méthodes de
professionnel
tout comme l'arme utilisée un fusil de
chasse à canonier
pour la police il s'agit donc d'amateurs
mais très doué
malgré les caméras de vidéosurveillance
placées à l'hôpital et sur l'ensemble de
leur parcours les enquêteurs perdent
leur trace aujourd'hui le tueur et son
complice n'ont toujours pas été
retrouvés mais leur mode opératoire
conduit les policiers à s'interroger
[Musique]
et si l'embuscade n'avait pas visé
Hélène Pastor mais plutôt Mohamed
Darwich son chauffeur la rumeur
s'emballe Mohamed Darwich aurait un
casier judiciaire il s'agirait d'un
règlement de compte une grande partie de
sa famille travaille pour les pasteurs à
Monaco tous ont refusé de s'exprimer
mais son ami rafatissa tient à parler
pour démentir la rumeur il est le
président d'une association
franco-égyptienne de la région
absolument rien à reprocher ni dans sa
vie professionnelle et ni dans sa vie
privée parce que c'est impossible de
travailler à Monaco et avec un casier
judiciaire ça c'est la première fois
deuxième point vous aimez imaginez
madame pasteur avec l'envergure qu'il a
l'important c'est qu'il a dans cette
principale dans le principe de Monaco
l'engager quelqu'un avec un casier
judiciaire donc c'est impossible
rapidement la police abandonne la piste
du chauffeur d'Hélène Pastor d'autres
hypothèses sont alors évoquées le mode
opératoire des tueurs rappelle la mafia
italienne très présente dit-on dans le
secteur de l'immobilier on parle aussi
des oligarques russes qui chercheraient
eux aussi à contrôler le marché
monégasque mais plus de nouvelles pistes
sont évoquées plus le mystère de la mort
d'Hélène Pastor s'épaissit
il est extrêmement difficile de faire
une hypothèse sur l'assassinat d'Hélène
Pastor pour une raison précise elle
n'est rien on se sent ce qu'elle n'est
qu'une gestionnaire de fortune ni plus
ni moins certes sa fortune est
importante sur une hauteur qu'on ignore
mais sans doute en milliard certaines
gèrent des immeubles mais gérer des
immeubles ne fait pas d'elle une cible
le mode opératoire est un mode qui
ressemble à celui de la mafia mais ça
peut être un camouflage SL qui est visée
quelle hypothèse peut-on émettre au fond
aucune en ce sens qu'on peut tout à fait
imaginer que tout le monde se sente
menacé reste encore la piste familiale
la plus complexe à percer selon la
rumeur il existerait des rivalités
profondes au sein de la famille Pastor
mais le clan a toujours réussi à garder
ses secrets sur son lit d'hôpital juste
avant de mourir elle aime Pastor à
chuchoter quelques mots aux enquêteurs
mais c'était pour leur dire qu'elle ne
savait pas qui pouvait lui en vouloir